hey guys Dennis here and I'm David your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of the series
premiere of true detective which airs on
HBO marina Matthew McConaughey and Woody
Harrelson I've been looking forward to
this for a while yeah it's it's probably
probably I want to say it's still early
in the year this is probably the most
hyped show so far of the year it's still
early I mean just because of wood
because you know there is the Matthew
McConaughey's yes it's going on right
now and yeah he's just turn it up yeah
yeah I mean mud dialysis club even his
ten minutes in wolf of Wall Street
amazing and now you have true detective
which the season premier I thought was
pretty good and was so cool about true
detective is that he's planes about who
he doesn't normally do he isn't this is
not him even in dice dice about scope as
good as he is he still kind of like at
that Southern drawl like I'm Woody
Harrelson going on here he's not like
all right all right all right how you
doing he's not doing that he kind of off
his rocker and he's a little crazy
little crazy like all he's all his
thoughts about like you know how he has
the cross but he he he did he's not
religious no he's a guy who reads a lot
of books and he's he's not like against
religion but he's not he's just yeah
he's an odd guy he's got a lot of weird
books in his house you know he's cousin
everything this didn't have a match
there is a mattress doesn't even have
like a bedpost or anything I mean is
he's just he's an odd dude and together
the great thing about the show to start
off is that good to see the guys in 1995
and we could see him in 2012 being
interviewed by a couple detectives yeah
they're they're talking about obviously
from from the premiere you know that
they've parted ways they're not friends
anymore and and the the show shows in
1995 the beginning of their partnership
and probably a friendship right yeah
because it's weird cuz you have Woody
Harrelson playing a character who's
actually the straight man right he's the
normal one right which Woody Harrelson
does a lot of pretty natural born killer
yeah if you saw out of the furnace yeah
like he always plays crazy I would he
can be crazy goofy or crazy this one
he's the normal which McConaughey is
usually the straight-laced guy yeah yeah
it was almost flipped and I
I have to ask you the show is really
good and I know you did get to watch all
these shows but I think as good as a
show is last year and 2013 there were a
lot of shows about murders yes in
strange town so let's go top of the lake
broadchurch Luther touches on similar
subjects like that Hannibal the killing
the killing there's a lot of great
dramas out right now that deal with
serial killers what it does to the mile
or does the people that pursue these
serial killers and how it affects their
lives so as good as this show is and as
well shot the guy who did the
cinematographer who did top at the lake
shot this now was a gorgeous show too
it's like we've seen this a lot lately
so when I was watching so like this is
really good but I was a little fatigued
during some of its I'm like I've seen so
many of these shows this past the fall i
first mentioned the fall with gillian
anderson another show about a serial
killer but it's still well done I don't
take away look how well done well I read
a interview with I think the show runner
is it this one writer and one director
who does everything and the writer said
that he's not interested in Syria colors
like the show's not about even though
that that's the case that they're
working you know with this ritual is to
killington he said it's about the
characters about rusty rust or whatever
the hell Matthew what kind of his cares
yeah yeah and Woody Harrelson's
character Martin and and I think it's
about their relationship and right and I
guess how it fell apart yeah I think so
too and I like that because you can kind
of tell the beginning when let there be
an interview and was like why do you
keep asked about that that night at the
dinner table like well why do you want
to know about that like why would you go
like you know so that you can tell the
are going to talk about the characters
and what makes them tick and the
relationship and like I said because
they said their partners for seven years
so what happens in that seven-year
period hopefully get to see a lot of
that and there's only seven more hours
of the show left but this is good i mean
it's it's so well done we haven't chance
these top of the lake but the
cinematography is just it's the same guy
it's gorgeous Lina three force of the
first step is ok you can tell this is
beautifully shot New Zealand this is in
you know I don't know where the shoot it
but I mean supposed to be outside of
Louisiana I mean it's are in Louisiana
it's just a it's a great-looking again
hpo style it's like a movie yeah it's
slow moving it's not a fast movie
channel HBO is not really known for
like bam bam bam you know it's a slow
burn but it's slowly developing and I
feel like as the season goes on there's
only two episodes that then it's gonna
start you know we're getting I remember
like something like the wire I think it
took me like 10 episodes before I was
like okay now I'm hope yeah the wire
doesn't hook you quick no it doesn't
either yeah I think that's what this
shows gonna be like it's very good so
far Melia and this is again just just
pulling weeds is nitpicking but i don't
think the female characters are gonna be
a big part of this which I love strong
female characters you know about
psychological of spartacus and i just
ate Michelle Moynihan I'm like I think
she's just gonna be the wife I'm morning
connect I always called her the I mean
she's like Sandra Bullock to me like a
lesser version maybe that one hand can
act but I feel like she's not going to
be a crucial part this is gonna be about
the men this is a study about the men
we've seen so many of those I would like
to see maybe some more female character
interaction I feel like they're just be
there gonna be strippers because the the
opening cinematic the opening sequence I
mean this is one shot with this butt
crack and then like high heels with like
spikes out of the back of them I mean so
I hope females aren't hope there's some
more diverse versity with the females I
don't think we're gonna get it in the
show yeah I think it really is about
Matthew McConaughey and Woody Harrelson
suppose two actors who were big-time
yeah yeah we got him for this you know 8
episode arc right and so they're gonna
use them as much as they can and he's
great i mean McConaughey just I mean
what he says being woody what he's
always doing here that's always good you
know he's just solid but I mean
McConaughey is doing a great job he's
it's hard to take his utter your eyes
off him while he's on screen he's doing
a great job yeah and he's one scene
where he's drunk and he goes to dinner
right Horford at woody harrelson scared
he's going to get rid of them he's like
well not only that he's trying to save
face for him he doesn't want his wife to
know and they kind of agreed that he was
gonna call someone right pick him up and
then at some point rust besides hey I'm
gonna stick around right cuz his those
guys are both messed up cuz what he
plays the straight-laced guy and plays
the guys who all together but there's a
few scenes especially once in the
beginning somebody walks in the office
you know like you know lady there he
probably having an affair I'm assuming
you know I mean he's plays like he's a
straight-laced guy but he's got issue
to not as many issues is you know matt
conahey but he does have some mission
McConaughey's character also we get
hints that his his kid died yeah we
don't yeah yeah yeah yeah we don't know
why right or how he's got a tough fast
he's got some something you know right
which hopefully will work out laters the
series continues I mean it is good it's
it just manage so many shows about
serial killers all right now like I
guess on those like I loved him I
couldn't keep watching the following
because it's just too much like it was
too much serial killer broadchurch
Luther top of the legs is too much
people died in you know but these are it
seems like what's what's in right now
this is like the not zombies but I
really liked it I thought it was a great
start i think i think as it develops
more i think it's going to get even
better yeah i think so so i don't know
if you guys see saw it let us know what
you thought you can post your comments
below on the website to CARICOM or on
our youtube channel think here I'll pro
make sure you subscribe to that lets you
can check us out on twitter talk to
dennis michael myself about true
detective you know or you hate another a
free show we've got girls in bed
watching girls out there you know later
on me I like girls not based on Tina
Dunham I'm down so let us know what you
think we're at think here i'm at griffin
de and a we also have a Facebook page
that's a facebook.com slash think hero
fans make sure you like that page make
sure you share our videos on Twitter and
Facebook and other social networks
you